hurt I'm sorry I got I got a boo-boo I'm
sorry buddy dude I'm out for a while you
are how to cancel a fight oh I'm sorry
so what my attack on you just now did
that hurt you no no you know why because
I left it all out there I know you did I
read all the Articles did you see though
I didn't see it I saw it you did you did
yeah the highlights yeah yeah yeah was
it good crazy it really was going for it
you're really fine dude thank you I
would love to actually be there the next
time you fight good news for you is
there a storyline where he comes with
you no chance why why why why why
I'm a good Corner man what's your name
what what's your record gotta get a
character
I just beat that up
Boston I'm from Boston yeah I mean I'm
doing my golden I like it right dude
Wrestlemania Wrestlemania next year yeah
in LA and you don't not my birthday
right April 1st you know what I'm gonna
do dude I'm gonna dreadlocks my hair or
is that too is that like Booker T yeah
can I dreadlock in my hair I think you
could I think you're Asian I think maybe
it's okay yeah right I'll do a
Rastafarian dreadlock you'll get hit for
cultural Appropriations yeah I don't
want to do that no but I think I think
you might have a pass with your name
like the cholo culture in Japan they
almost get a pass yeah
um so maybe I'll do a cholo thing
oh yeah but I'm doing my gold though but
he has the real backpack from boss I'm
from Boston
but he really could be a good cornerman
because you have a background in
wrestling I do have I have a background
wrestling yeah I was on the wrestling
team in high school were you good I feel
like you were okay well my my seat why
would you say that about him you seem
Stout dude you seem stable dude ask
coach randstadter right I was very good
especially on the bottom
you could stand up and Escape no no I
did this thing called the egg roll I
know the egg roll look shut the front
door yeah yeah no way there you go dude
no hey Bobby that wait that was me dude
hold on dude yeah that could be anyone
no no no that could be [ __ ] me dude
that doesn't even look like go go to the
high school yearbook of Poway High
School you can Google it hey by the way
those wrestling photos were the most
awkward to take no yeah they were how
you supposed to look badass in a
wrestling stance that's so stupid I
don't know but look at that that was me
right I was good at the bottom okay and
I did this thing called the egg roll I
know the rule what you know the egg roll
it's called the Granby roll the Granby
wall right right
the egg roll
oh maybe I should have called them out
for racism that you could have but what
is it called a Granby role yeah I should
say Granby
no [ __ ] it's Eggroll
wow anyway they called it it's a good
move and I would grab their so if they
had me on it right I could grab this and
I would flip this arm back I was able to
[ __ ] uh hit the reverse uh you're on
my team it's official I have to pitch it
to WWE that would be amazing yeah but
like I could use a I could use a uh
I could use a corner man I could use a
cut man what do you have I don't know
about the cut man thing no why why he
just doesn't you don't have a hospitable
bone caretaker oh yeah his fingers
show me your thumbs
what's so wrong with those thumbs yeah
what's wrong with my thumbs um they're
like bitten into yeah people bite their
they're bitten into yeah people bite
that by what
they're like you're missing half of it
hold on hold on yeah
doesn't look like it from here thank you
so much dude and I appreciate that she's
just [ __ ] it's that same thing that
rage inside yeah yeah
yeah yeah you didn't happen we'll keep
some of it in
I did a call back but my point is it's
all right this is what I'm so confused
when you get into a relationship with
someone new the person isn't
perturbed by the fact that you're still
on a podcast with your ex
um I'm not